Welcome back everyone
i's Charlie Marvel just revealed
what Punisher is doing during Daredevil
Born again season 1
and what's going on with Foggy
Nelson and Karen Page coming back.
So we'll break it all down.
I know a lot of you have been asking
what's going on with them coming back
because there's been reports about them
not being in season one.
Don't worry. I'll explain everything.
of course.
I'll be doing videos for all the episodes
of your brand new to the channel.
Be sure to subscribe
to get all the episodes.
There's 18 episodes in season one,
even though they're breaking it
and they should all air next year.
Even though there's been some delays
recently.
there's also that movie Ticket giveaway
we're in the middle of.
So I'll name a winner during this video to
but a while ago
it was revealed to our surprise
that Jon Bernthal would also be coming
back as the Punisher during Daredevil
Born again. Maybe not surprised.
I think we all wanted him to come back,
but it was just eventually confirmed
a little while ago.
now we've learned that his role will be
way bigger than your typical one off
cameos like Blink
and you'll miss a kind of cameo.
His story will be a significant part
of the plot with what Daredevil himself
and Kingpin are doing during the series.
typically you think of the show
just being about daredevil and kingpin
because they always attend
Comic-Con panels together.
They do a lot of conventions together,
so it's typically just the two of them.
but think of Punisher during season
one as being like one of the third
main characters
when the series was supposed to pick up.
A little time has gone by
since the events of Secret Invasion.
President Ritson
declared war on the Skrulls.
during the finale,
we saw people running around in mobs
all over the streets, killing everybody
in sight on the suspicion
that they might be skrulls.
and they were like Punisher
level vigilantes, just like regular dudes
running around in mobs
trying to kill everybody that they thought
might be a squirrel
killing a bunch of innocent people.
so there is this chaos all over the world.
Everybody's
clamoring for security, for safety
And you have a bunch of just regular dudes
all over the planet
starting to think of themselves
as the Punisher.
Like that's the vibe in response
to that, law enforcement agencies
have to act in kind down
to the regular police officers
on the street getting really violent,
mostly because they're dealing
with mobs of regular people
running around,
shooting everything that moves.
but as the broader sense of fear,
dread starts setting in
with the population around the world,
people start getting paranoid
protection, security
become their most important concerns.
And even though this is happening
all over the world did of a born again
mostly localized to the New York City area
local police started getting more and more
aggressive and violent in their tactics.
It became this big commentary
for police brutality.
But it's all because of what happened
with President Ritson in the Skrulls.
some of the police
start to take example from the Punisher
who is cannon to the MCU again.
Now people were wondering
what the cannon was going to be like.
What is Cannon from the Marvel Netflix
shows from the Punisher
series from daughter of a born again
Jessica Jones Iron Fist, Luke Cage.
Who'd be coming back, The vast
majority of what Punisher and Daredevil
did during their Netflix series,
like Daredevil in the Punisher
series are mostly not like 100%,
but mostly Cannon.
sort of like a piecemeal thing.
Like once Jessica Jones comes back,
most of her stuff will become canon again,
too, but not until she comes back.
so everyone in the universe knows
the Punisher exists.
The police remember him
from the events of the Punisher series.
They start to adopt his more hardcore
tactics
because of all these vigilantes
running around in the streets
in a bunch of corrupt police officers.
Start using his punisher symbol
to do a bunch of shady stuff,
which is a big commentary
on police brutality.
but in the context of the MCU
it's a bunch of corrupt cops
using his symbol not all the police
so apparently
at the beginning of the series
when things pick up,
Punisher spends the early part of that
not the whole season,
but at least when it picks up
going after these corrupt cops
that are using his Punisher symbol
to do whatever they want,
like all the shady stuff
that they can get their hands on.
Normally Punisher
would love to see law enforcement
take a tougher stance on crime,
but I think the idea is
that the dirty cops are either
killing innocent people
or they're just being worse
than actual criminals
or committing a lot of crimes themselves.
pretty dark day when the Punisher
feels like you've crossed the line
and you're dragging his good name
through the mud.
there was something similar
that happened in real life.
Marvel Comics, not Marvel Studios,
like not the movie stuff, but on the comic
book side, they had to change.
Punisher Symbol for a while
just because there were
a bunch of real life
police officers using it
and they thought
it was really distasteful.
So it turned in this whole big thing
a couple of years ago.
so if you wonder in the comics
why Punisher
hasn't been using his traditional Punisher
symbol.
That's why while he's busy
dealing with that during the episodes,
Kingpin has been running
for mayor of New York City
using an anti vigilante campaign,
which is right out of the comics.
Daredevil
and Punisher are both vigilantes,
so he essentially declares war on them.
People like them
and even though I never thought
of Spider-Man as a vigilante kingpin,
the cops treat him like one.
so his relationships, same as Daredevil
and Punisher's
is the same with the police.
Like the good cops appreciate their help.
But because the law treats
what they're doing is kind of illegal,
even though they're helping people,
technically the police have to try
and arrest them every chance they get
there are good cops on the force
that are trying to help them
work with them,
or at least allow them to do what
they do a lot of people wondering
what's going on with Spider-Man.
During the events of Daredevil Born Again.
A little time has gone by
since the end of Spider-Man. No Way Home.
there was a funny scene of Matt with Happy
Hogan, him trying to defend him.
Matt Murdock is still been doing stuff
like that.
Spider-Man has still been busy
trying to finish his GED
and just act like friendly neighborhood
Spider-Man in the comics.
they didn't say exactly what month
Daredevil Born Again takes place,
but like a little bit of time has gone by,
I don't think that Spider-Man
has started his freshman year
in college yet.
most of Tom Holland's focus in real life
in the MCU is on Spider-Man four.
So I don't expect him to cross over
into Daredevil season one,
but they'll probably reference Spider-Man
or have a Jonah Jameson
cameo scene with him yelling about
Spider-Man and Daredevil Punisher.
Skrulls all kinds of vigilantes.
It feels like a very J.
Jonah Jameson thing for him to do.
Kevin Big did confirmed
there will be some crossover
between Daredevil and Spider-Man
during Spider-Man four.
But I think he was mostly talking
about Daredevil and maybe Kingpin
two appearing in the movie,
not Spider-Man appearing on the series
Marvel and Sony are really picky
about Tom Holland's Spider-Man
appearing on TV stuff like even during the
What If series, most of the movie
actors came back as their characters,
except for Tom Holland's Spider-Man.
He was one of the few
that did not do that.
mostly because they don't want him
being in like a billion different things,
which is why
I think that Sony is trying to introduce
their own version of Spider-Man
or like bring Andrew Garfield
or Tobey Maguire back to be in
some of their Spider-Man spinoff movies.
So the Tom Holland doesn't
have to be in like every single one.
it is definitely not more Ben time
or craven time for Tom Holland's
Spider-Man yet
all this stuff during Daredevil, Bourne,
again, is meant to be part of the Dark
Reign era of Marvel Phase five
that'll culminate during Captain America
four Brave New World.
When Thunderbolt Ross becomes
the President in the United States,
he and Kingpin essentially rule
their territory, so to speak, with
Iron Fist to make as many defenders puns
as possible.
the difference is that Kingpin
is just mostly localized to the New York
City area like mayor of New York City
versus being the president United States.
while he's busy running for mayor,
Daredevil is not working at Nelson Murdock
and Page anymore.
When the series begins,
Foggy Nelson, Karen Page still can
into the MCU in the series But like.
During She-Hulk he was at a different law
firm when he was visiting Los Angeles
to get those new suits will continue
at the beginning of Daredevil born again.
But they will explain why Foggy and Karen
aren't around at the beginning.
Their absence is supposed to be
a big plot point,
meaning that they will come back
eventually.
a lot of people worried
that they would just
completely get rid of those characters.
So I wouldn't worry too much about that.
little while ago,
Charlie Cox even spoke about Karen Page,
saying that she was basically
always going to be best girl,
even if they didn't start Date
of a Born Again with them being together.
supposedly
they'll explain why all three of them,
Matt, Foggy and Karen
haven't
been working together in present day,
but because they're breaking
the season in half.
my assumption is that foggy
and Karen will have some kind of flashback
in the first half of the episodes
and maybe in the second half
or during season two,
they'll come back for real
in a bigger way.
they haven't said what Season two
is going to be about, only that we know
they will do a season two at some point.
Hopefully there isn't a huge break.
Like I said, season one, 18 episodes.
There's going to be a break in the middle.
Typical season of television.
They were originally supposed
to start airing episodes spring 2024,
but with the reason delays
because of the strikes,
I think they'll probably try
to premiere in the summer,
meaning they might air
the second half at the end of next year.
one of the big changes
is the date of a Born Again was like
one of the first series that Kevin Foggy
was able to address A lot of people's
complaints about these six episode
Marvel events, quote unquote.
they're trying to make it
their new major series with way
more effort going into it.
That's why they greenlit for 18 episodes
in season one instead of the typical six
or nine episodes.
They knew it was going to be
a much bigger deal for them.
I think the extra episode order
was also part of Kevin Peggy's
response to the complaints over the short
six episode runs
that weren't really designed to be TV
shows.
Marvel always thought of them
as more like movie scripts
that never actually made it into movies,
like a bunch of extra scripts
they had just lying around on the shelf
like, Hey,
let's just air
this in six different
episodes. We'll just chop it up instead of
turning it into actual television
episodes.
that's one of the reasons why
a lot of the pacing
on some of these smaller
Marvel shows feels really weird because
they were never designed to be TV shows.
Date of a Born Again, on the other hand,
was always designed from the ground up
to be a traditional TV show.
So I think it'll all just flow a lot,
but I think we'll just feel a lot better.
Let me know in the comments.
Which of the characters
do you want to see crossover
onto Daredevil Born again In related news.
Big reminder
Asuka episodes start next week.
Of course
I'll be doing videos for everything.
Be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss any of those
Congratulations Mike b4226.
You're the giveaway winner from my Blue
Beetle video. Please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your contact details.
Click here for that new Thunderbolt Sentry
teaser and click here for My Doctor
Strange 3 video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!